are you good
are you good yes or no up and down if
you're good side to side no
yeah you're good
i love you i love you you're gonna get a
raise he can furnish a fastball with the
best of them lancelin second best era
in the majors it'll be the lance lynn
against robbie grossman to start
on a thursday night in chicago
uh here is candelario who is on an
on-base streak at 28 games now it's the
longest
in major league baseball this season
there he goes there's the strikeout
throw to second that is the throw em out
there you go there it is lots of ways to
get a double play and that's one of them
he has money made a good throw he got
rid of it quickly but there's the
strikeout
tipped into the glove it's a live ball
and i think tim is shaking up a bit you
see the tag on the hip
well before the leg got there and left
to his own devices these days he'll hit
it to right or right center
cabrera into right adam eaton has room
and that will do it for the tigers
threat in the first inning socks will
bad t.a
first when we come back
casey maize towing the rubber for the
tigers tonight
it's his uh 11th start of the season and
tim anderson
told me before the game you've got to
see it
up against casey mize here's the 1-1
on the ground to third candelario
smoothly done
one away hottest hitter in this lineup
right now these next two batters monkana
and debrejo
[Music]
hits a splitter to left grossman back at
the wall
out of here
so they were talking to the pregame show
about monkata as an mvp
frank said maybe it's that the power is
not there
uh there you go 35 one nothing sucks
now the disadvantage is no force out
because the runners are going to be
going
three and two from lin to badou
[Applause]
it was a little bit up and badou had the
willpower to take it so
the nine-hitter rogers is gonna hit with
the bases loaded and here comes ethan
cat
there are a few key moments in any
baseball game where if you make your
pitch if you get your man out it'll be a
lot easier to win that game
this is one of those moments you're
facing number nine in the batting order
and you got the bases loaded
two-strike pitch there he goes
i love when lance gets fired up
[Applause]
lamb had a good series against the
tigers that first series
jake crushes this ball right field that
is a solo shot
look out goose tune up in
you keep the ball down and he's going to
hit it a long way
mize did and so did jake
sox fans saw what happened last
homestand
with his home runs in back-to-back games
power they got some decent speed
here's the o2 to hamilton drives one to
left field
grossman is there but chicago pads their
lead another two out solo homer
bottom third of the order castro bedouin
rogers against lancelin fly ball
right field off the bat of willie castro
deep got a chance come on
a solo bomb for willy castro to lead off
the fifth
and the tigers are on the board it's 2-1
chicago one down for rogers who came up
in a huge spot in the second
inning and lance vanquished him on three
pitches
another 3-2 tonight from lynn and he
struck him out
busted him on another cutter and ramped
up to 94.
single and a bounce out for grossman
three shift to the right mankata in
tight
in the air left-hand side lamb
makes a catch twitch hitting
jamer candelario batting from the left
side
the 1-0 to candelario fly ball
off the end of the bat and it drops in
for a lead-off single
might be the best pitch lance lynn threw
to candy all game
like a split finger that's the way that
ball came out of his hand didn't know he
had that pitch
so good for candy as on base streak
continues
and that is a career high for him 29
consecutive
granddaughter ii reached down on errors
last time
right field we have a new constellation
in the night sky 3-1 socks
see he was thinking about hitting a home
run a wuzzy
and it's another run lead the third solo
homer
and that folks is a big one tonight
3-1 chicago bottom of the seventh inning
but he's due to come off 1-1 to garcia
on the ground to first casey mize gives
up the solo homer
retires the white sox here in the
seventh it's a 3-1
chicago edge
anderson the batter 1-4-3
in this one
9-1-1 tim gives it a ride centerfield
it is
tim's wanted that one for a while his
first homer since may the 13th
and the sox with a solo home run
barrage are up four to one
a very pumped closer and liam hendricks
going to the well for
his 14th save and this is 16th
opportunity
2-2 from hendricks to scope
strike three so the white sox
and end the night with a three-game lead
if they can hold on
oh what first base
abreu snares it nice pick hendricks is
there and
two away the tigers are still alive for
at least another batter down
three
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
on the ground at third it's monkana with
hendricks gets the save two pitches
later
four solo shots for the sox and a 4-1
series opening win for your first place
chicago white sox